guys I'll be honest this is a I I can't
play this piece of it's actually
terrible it's a terrible game a few
months ago Tyler one took a break from
League of Legends and went on an
absolute chess Rampage he has since
returned properly though and on a recent
stream this week he went on a rant
against the game that was so hate filled
so vicious that it has people genuinely
wondering is Tyler one done with
League all right so as I'm sure many of
you are aware Tyler one has been
medically diagnosed as being built
different a few months ago everyone was
losing their minds that the toxic SL
reformed League streamer was seemingly
Conquering the Chess
World not the bishop in two months of
playing time Tyler 1 has played 40 to 50
rapid chess games every single day he
has stopped streaming his puzzles rating
is
2500 2,500 he has done over 7500 puzzles
he has played over 20300 rapid games and
he has now played even hundreds of Blitz
Games I don't think there has ever been
a dedication to chess quite like this I
think this man is more dedicated to
chess then hikarin nakura Magnus Carlson
and stockfish combined after months of
him grinding off stream and people
wondering how far he could actually go
tyan finally peaked at a chess.com
rating of 1548 which is absolutely
insane considering he was new to the
game basically just a few months before
at the time there was a lot of
speculation about why exactly he was
doing this maybe it was just for the
challenge this is a guy who famously got
Challenger in all five roles in League
of Legends after all but my theory and
one which I've heard echoed around the
place is that chess gave Tyler something
which League no longer could everyone
knows that having to rely on your
teammates for a win is one of the most
frustrating things about mob or FPS
games it doesn't feel that great to have
your rating and your sanity relying on
the effort levels of random strangers on
your team or the effectiveness of the
game's matchmaking system famously a
solo game that's not a problem chess has
I think Tyler one was drawn to chess as
a game where the bck stops with you
there is no one else to rely on or to
blame another reason is balancing now
League of Legends is notoriously a game
that changes quite a lot every year
sometimes multiple times a year one
minute a champion is perfectly fine
perhaps even a little on the weak side
Riot tweaks a few numbers and suddenly
you're thinking existence is futile and
happiness is an illusion and if you're
someone like Tyler 1 who has played over
12,000 hours of league on stream and
probably multiple times that amount off
stream this just gets multiplied so
like you got to deal with the ghosting
scum every game you going to deal with
if your dog piss stting teammates on top
of that thank God if nobody's not win
trading boosting or account
sharing what the that was Tyler one
before he went on his insane chest run a
few months ago but to be honest if you
tune in a lot of top League of Legends
streamers you'll probably hear them say
something similar to that eventually and
of course we have heard similar rants
from Tyler one before to the point where
it would feel weird if he stopped
talking like that after a bad loss or a
losing streak but for some people the
rant he had this week just felt
different the devs have killed it they
everybody's miserable playing it like
people are miserable because the balance
is so bad tilts everybody so I probably
got like one game I'll probably play
like one game a day on like a like a
silver account just to post on YouTube
seriously this trash it is so bad I
cannot sit here and play this now a lot
of people on Reddit simply weren't
buying it they felt like they'd heard
this from Tyler before and I think it's
safe to say this is not really a
sentiment shared by the average player I
think ultimately we're looking at a man
here who has completed League of Legends
the last time I saw Tyler one looked
like he was truly enjoying the game game
was when he was grinding to get
Challenger in all five roles he had a
purpose it breathed fresh life into a
game that he's played more than anyone I
know over the past seven years D it's
done
yes he also seemed to enjoy the absolute
hard mode challenge of trying to climb
in soloq with Ivan and as someone who
enjoys Ivan myself in fact you can see a
picture of him right there I respect the
challenge it's definitely a challenge
definitely keeps you engaged now Tyler
would probably disagree with me here and
say that look if Riot simply fixed
champion and item designs and balance
matchmaking properly then he'd be happy
but I don't think so the game has never
been perfect Tyler started playing and
streaming League of Legends in the 2014
to 2016 era the game was a mess back
then in many ways trust me I was there
the r glaive meta the Juggernaut meta
the black cleav meta these were some
dark days in League of Legends a lot of
people feel that League of Legends is
generally in a better State balancing
wise than it was 10 years ago or even 5
years ago of course there are going to
be busted things from time to time of
course some patches are going to be
worse than others but we're talking
generally here and for some people the
future looks bright the recently
announced season 14 changes have
promised to do away with the
controversial Mythic items which many
players felt have put too much focus on
what items a player had rather than
which champion they were playing and we
can also expect sweeping changes to the
map and neutral objectives that have
players cautiously optimistic at worst
and even excited at best but not Tyler
and people are saying well season 14
they're changing all the items it'll be
better it's going to be the same thing
it's there's going to be broken again
it's they're going do the same exact
things again it's just a shame on the
devs for what they've done to this game
every single one of you shame on you and
look I know Tyler one is the Challenger
player I know he he's been playing the
game for a living for S years at this
point in many ways he's the expert here
he seems sincere when he says that this
time the devs really have killed the
game later on in that clip he went on to
say that they're simply changing the
game to justify their paychecks and
while I think that's a pretty cutting
way of putting it there is some truth to
it League of Legends is a game built on
change players that stop playing the
game are often enticed back at the start
of a new season wanting to try out the
new changes for themselves and if a few
Champions items or roles get tuned in
the process I think Riot sees that as
reasonable collateral damage if Riot
wanted to pretty much perfectly balance
League of Legends a little bit like
chess they probably could have at this
point they've had over a decade they are
a massive company it's well within their
means and I get it it's really
frustrating when your solo Q games feel
like they're decided by The Meta of the
month and this is something the pro
scene has had to struggle with since the
Inception of LoL Esports teams will work
their asses off trying to get really
good at a specific matter their jobs are
on the line and then Riot just flips the
whole game on its head sometimes
dangerously close to a new tournament so
in some ways I do take Tyler's point and
he does seem sincere when he says he
can't play the game but until he does
actually quit until he uninstalls the
game and stop streaming it people are
always going to see this as just him
crying wolf and sure enough after all of
this after going on that huge rant Tyler
did in fact return to League the
following day yes now I know what you're
probably thinking yo what's up T what
happened bro you said yesterday you were
done yeah bro I got bored Tyler went on
to say that he was back in part because
he didn't want to play chess right now
it had been less than 24 hours and
League had already sucked him back in a
lot of people do have this kind of toxic
relationship with the game I think it's
just more visible with Tyler you're
frustrated by it but you're addicted to
it it makes you feel like and want to
play other games but you keep coming
back to it on top of all that for Tyler
he also makes a ton of money
playing and streaming the game as one of
the biggest Western streamers even if
his content revolves around him hating
on the game he still draws in massive
audiences in some cases probably because
of it so is Tyler one done with League
of Legends mentally yes I think he has
been for a while now literally though I
don't think
so I actually think that the end of
Tyler one's story will be him becoming a
League of Legends de like imagine him
being like the riot August of League of
Legends like you see a new Champion come
out and you see it's been designed by
Tyler you see him doing all the patch
TRS and stuff there aren't many people
out there who have played the game more
than him he clearly has a passion for
balance should we say